[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
time to resume david so okay yeah so
first let me take any questions from the
from the last talk if there are any
don't have any yeah
oh sure in case people are not we're not
here yeah okay so you know what we did
is we we're studying dimensionality
reduction in the context of least
squares regression we introduced the
notion of a subspace embedding showing
that if you have a subspace you can
reduce its dimension to something much
smaller and preserve the norms of every
vector in that subspace and that was the
basic primitive that we use for
regression that sort of immediately
implied algorithms for regression the
question is you know how do you do the
dimensionality reduction what kind of
random matrices do you use we saw that
Gaussian matrices work but they're too
slow I also mentioned the subsampled
randomized Hadamard transform which is
faster and which can will give a proof
on tomorrow and we focus mostly on count
sketch which was very good for sparse
input matrices and and so we were in the
proof of showing that count sketch gives
a subspace embedding and so yeah so fine
so in that proof we said that you know
all it comes down to is showing an
approximate matrix product with
Frobenius norm error because that upper
bounds and operator norm error and the
operator norm error was enough to get a
subspace embedding so then we started
looking at how can we achieve this
Frobenius norm error and we said that
you know this is an approximate matrix
product and so we said okay so let's
look at you know distributions on
matrices S which satisfy what is called
the jl moment property meaning that they
preserve norms of fixed vectors with
good probability and we said if they
have this property then they have this
approximate matrix product property that
we want so that's what we proved last
time and so we're finally left in the
proof of just showing that this count
sketch matrix does have this jail moment
property and so we started by showing it
has the right expectation it preserves
norms it's unbiased and I'm just going
to quickly mention
a variance calculation but I won't get
into the detail yeah one point is counts
pitch does not give you the
exponentially small failure probability
so you cannot just do the that's correct
so as I kind of hinted at so these
bounds are tight for count sketch so if
I apply count sketch to D by D identity
matrix you know what I'm doing is I'm
hashing the rows of this identity matrix
into buckets k buckets if K is the
number of rows in my count sketch and
the problem is if if two of these rows
collide into the same bucket then I only
have D minus 1 nonzero rows in my image
s times 8 D minus 1 nonzero rows I mean
I'm not going to have you know rank
larger than B minus 1 which means I
can't preserve a D dimensional subspace
so really the question is just you know
if I throw D balls into how many how
many bins do I need so that if I throw D
balls into them I'll have you know 1
minus Delta success probability of them
all getting perfectly hashed right and
so you sort of need at least d squared
rows just for constant probability sort
of d squared over Delta is that is where
that bound was coming for a higher
probability yeah and you know so there
was some complaint boy you know it's a
linear dependence in Delta how can you
do better some of these other works I
alluded to or instead of choosing a
single nonzero entry per column if you
choose like a hundred nonzero entries
per column or a log deed number of
nonzero entries per column they achieve
not only a better dependence on D so
instead of d squared you get like D to
the 1.1 but they also achieve a better
dependence on Delta yeah so that's the
summary any other questions
okay Marco or no okay so one other
question that came up was you know we're
getting a polynomial dependence in in in
epsilon so the the time is proportional
to like is Polly polynomial and D over
Epsilon
and for some of the you know statistics
people in the audience this is totally
not acceptable you'd like epsilon to be
very small so one thing we'll see in
this talk is how to use sketching as a
pre-conditioner for gradient descent for
what you can get a logarithmic
dependence on one over epsilon and
therefore you can set up salon be really
small like one over square root n if n
is your number of examples and this will
be you know more suited for those
applications okay if there no other
questions and I'll just continue okay so
yeah so we showed that you know if we if
we choose account sketch matrix s then
this expected value of the square norm
of SX is the squared norm of X it was
unbiased now what we needed to show was
this junior moment property so we want
to show the jail moment property here
with l equals two so we really need to
compute the expectation of the square
norm of s X minus one squared okay now I
can expand that Square and I'll get the
expectation of you know the fourth power
of the norm of SX you know minus twice
the squared norm of SX which I've
already computed the expectation for
plus one so really this comes down to
understanding what is the expectation of
the fourth power of the norm of s times
X that's all we need to compute and
you know so it's a mess
okay I'm not going to do it in the talk
just for to keep the keep things simple
but really it's it's very simple okay so
all you do is you know so this is the
expectation of the fourth power of the
norm of SX so this is you know the
square norm of SX squared so I have you
know sort of two copies of what I had
before I have
you know some over the K coordinates
something over J and I also have a sum
over K court and summing over J Prime
and I have both of those expressions
that I had before and really all this is
is you know a second moment calculation
I mean so you can write out the whole
thing I don't expect you to parse this
on the fly but you know what it comes
down to is you again have these random
signs inside of each of the expectations
and if you remember for the expectation
calculation we said that if I look at
Sigma I 1 times Sigma I 2 and I 1 is not
equal to I 2 then that expectation is 0
and so now it's a little bit more
complicated I have an expectation of
Sigma I 1 times Sigma I 2 times Sigma 3
times Sigma 4 when is that expectation
nonzero so I have to be able to group
these indices into pairs to get a
nonzero expectation so for instance they
could all be equal to each other and
then I'll get some expression here that
I can calculate or maybe these two are
equal and these two are equal but
they're not equal to each other so I
just go through each of the cases and I
bound this expression it's not very
interesting it's very straightforward so
you do it there's some slides they know
the math is here just for archival
purposes but at the end of the day what
you get is that the expected value of
the fourth norm the fourth power of the
norm of SX is between 1 and 1 plus order
1 over K where K is the number of rows
in your count sketch okay that's what
you get and so you know now we're going
to show that count sketch has this day a
moment property so we wanted to you know
for for the value L the moment equaling
2 so we have to look at the expectation
of the squared value of this squared
norm of SX minus 1 and you know just
expanding it we plug in 1 plus 2 over K
for the expected value of the fourth
power of the norm of SX and then we have
minus 2 because it's minus twice the
expectation of the square norm of SX
plus 1 for that one and we get 2 over K
and if we just set the number of rows K
in our count sketch to be 2 divided by
epsilon squared Delta then this quantity
is
exactly what we want for the jail moment
property so that's all the proof does
any questions about that it's just a
calculation yeah would you not do higher
moments to so count sketches is already
tight so but again somewhat looking at
higher values of L is useful for some
other works so one work is by bore game
Dirksen and Nelson where they show that
if all the leverage scores of your
matrix a are small then you can get you
know better balance so just you can get
D rows instead of d squared rows one
thing they look at is is higher moments
for example yeah and the works that look
at the trade-offs number of non-zeros
per column instead of being one if I
have like a hundred nonzero is per
column you can look at higher moments
and get better bounce yeah for us l
equals two is enough yeah Fred yeah so
that's a great question so we're gonna
see how to do a log 1 over epsilon
dependence yeah
okay okay so just to wrap up so this was
the jail property we showed counts cos
satisfied it we also showed a transition
statement if you have the jail property
then you have a proximate matrix product
and if you remember that's all we needed
for the proof so we showed l equals two
and two over epsilon square Delta rows
suffice we wanted a matrix product
result of this form which is a little
bit different form than the form that's
proven here but it's really the same
thing okay so if I you know if I set
epsilon squared equals two over K Delta
and plug it in here then I get you know
six over Delta number of rows K and I
just make this Delta this is one minus
Delta it's the same expression okay so
so we're done with the proof that count
sketches the subspace embedding and
using the connection to regression we
get input sparsity time and NZ of a plus
polynomial and D over epsilon
any questions
okay great okay so let's move on to the
next thing I want to talk about which is
high-precision regression where we want
a better dependence on epsilon we want
like a log 1 over epsilon dependence
which one of them is more humid it could
escape
numerically stable meaning like the
condition number of something is good or
order backwards away um
I mean so okay so there are empirical
results on this maybe Michael knows
better than I do but I don't know about
the count scheduler actually but the
other ones can be
yeah I mean concept is extremely
practical and we have implementations on
it where it works well and it's a lot
faster than Gaussian matrices for
example but sometimes galti and matrices
have other properties like smoothing out
vectors which is useful for other things
like support vector machines etc okay
high precision regression so here is our
goal again we just want a 1 plus epsilon
approximation to regression and our
algorithms run in Pauly D of R epsilon
time but we would like Pauly D Times log
1 over Epsilon so the idea is to first
make our matrix a well conditioned ok so
the condition number for the purposes of
this talk of a cap of a is just you know
the maximum value of the norm of AX
divided by the minimum value of the
number of AX over all vectors X sorry
that you know the supremum of the norm
of AX over unit vectors X divided by the
infinim of the norm of AX over unit
vectors X and lots of algorithms time
complexity depends on the condition
number so be useful to have a generic
technique for reducing the condition
number
and so we're going to use sketching to
reduce kappa very to constant
okay so the idea is to let s be a 1 plus
epsilon zero subspace embedding for a
epsilon zero think of as a constant like
1/2 we first compute s times a say using
one of these count sketch matrices and
then we compute a QR factorization of s
times a ok so we write s times a let me
just write it as Q times R inverse where
Q has orthonormal columns okay and our
inverse is just chosen to satisfy this
equation now there are multiple
different queues you could choose just
choose one of them arbitrarily yes oh I
I mean I just want to define it like
this for the purposes of the proof I'm
just calling it R inverse so yeah sorry
yeah maybe I should called R but I'm
going to use it I don't want to write
inverses everywhere so this is a Q R
inverse vectors if you are in respective
you okay so something in a note here I
could have computed a QR factorization
or QR universe factorization of the
original matrix a but this would be slow
alright I mean in general this can take
like you know nd squared time instead
what I did is I sketch the problem down
to something small so the number of rows
of S is Polly D so this whole thing is
just Polly D by D and now I compute my
QR factorization of s times 8 in just
poly D time independent event and now
what do I do
so my claim here is that if I look at
the condition number of a times R it's 1
plus epsilon 0 over 1 minus epsilon 0
remember epsilon zero was this parameter
which I said is 1/2 say you know in that
case this would be 3 I can set this to
be any constant I don't want to decided
to be too small if I said it really
small then I spend Pauly D of R epsilon
time here so I wanted to have to be a
constant so this Pauly D time the thing
is that this wholeness
so just you know some perspective here
like I compute like a change of basis in
the skep space and I lift it up use that
same came to basis matrix that D by D
matrix in the original space so that
people see why this should be true
what do we know about s
so why should this be well-conditioned
yeah perfectly perfect right like so
okay so let's do what Ravi said so for
all unit vectors X what do we know about
the norm of SAR X well SAR if I multiply
both sides by our it adds orthonormal
columns so the norm of SAR X is just 1
if I apply to unit vector on the other
hand well s is a subspace embedding
right the substrates embedding a 1 plus
epsilon 0 approximate subspace embedding
so it's at least 1 minus epsilon 0 times
the norm of a our X this is for all
vectors X I can also do the other
direction right I mean again the norm of
SAR X is 1 as before and because it's a
subspace embedding it's at most the norm
of a are x times 1 plus epsilon 0
okay but now I just take the ratio all
right the condition number of AR is just
the you know the ratio of the the soup
of this over the Infinity the infidel
unit vectors X and what do we get since
this holds for all unit vectors X it
means the norm of AR X is at most one
over one minus epsilon zero and we also
know that the norm of AR x well it's at
least 1 over 1 plus epsilon zero so when
I do this division I just get 1 plus
epsilon zero over 1 minus epsilon zero
right okay so an N and Z of a plus Pauly
D time we computed you know a matrix R
which gives a good pre-conditioner now
what can we do
what can you do if your matrix is
well-conditioned how can you solve least
squares regression
what's that you can use no more
equations but have you have you gained
something by directly using normal
equations it's abused explicit form
that's the no more equations so we want
to avoid like you know nd square time
gradient descent right so gradient
descent typically the time for gradient
descent is in terms of the condition
number but our condition number is very
small now so okay so okay great descent
it also needs a good initial solution
you have to start somewhere where are we
going to start from well we're going to
start from a constant factor
approximation so again s is one of these
one plus say 1/2 subspace embeddings we
compute SAR SB we compute si then si
times R so this is N and Z of a plus
poly D time we solve this in poly G time
there's no dependence on the actual
epsilon and we get our constant factor
initial solution X 0
okay so we have our change of basis and
constant factor solution and now we just
run a gradient descent algorithm as you
guys suggested so let's do the update
rule that the new iterate xn plus 1 is
the old literate XM plus a transpose R
transpose times B minus a r XM okay so
you know B minus a r XM is you know
what's left over the residual in the
empty duration and you know we're
hitting it we're looking at what's left
over and we're taking the inner product
with the row span of of r transpose a
transpose so the column span of a R and
removing a little bit in that direction
this is my know so you'll see the proof
the whole proof will be on this slide
this is the step length is just 1 well
the nice thing here is that like the the
running time is going to depend on the
condition number but we've made the
condition number transpose the same yeah
so okay so let's look at the time
complexity of this so you know what am i
doing I'm never actually computing this
product R transpose times a transpose
yes yeah sure yeah that's all I'm doing
right so the important point to note to
note here is like I have XM I compute X
M times R and I have R X M that's a
vector I compute that times a day you
know I subtract that from B that's a
vector I compute that vector times a
transpose that vector times R transpose
I never have to compute the matrix
matrix products yeah sure sure sure I'm
just saying that like you know this will
just keep a very you know the use of
sketching here is is for the purposes of
making the condition number constant
okay if you don't have constant
condition number then are you going to
get input sparsity time n NZ of a time
times log 1 over epsilon so let's
revisit the question at the end of the
slide yeah ok ok so let's just look at
this quantity let's look at a R times
the n plus first iterate xn plus 1 minus
the optimal solution X star ok now all I
did on this right-hand side here is I
plugged in you know the definition of xn
plus 1 now this is the definition
okay
so I claim the following equality holds
and this is not so easy people I mean
not yeah we should expand this just to
see why this holds so I claim that AR X
M plus R transpose a transpose B minus a
r XM minus X star is equal to AR minus
AR
R transpose a transpose AR XM minus X
star okay so here I have a are XM minus
X star and here I have a are XM minus X
star right so what I really need to show
to show that this holds is I need to
show that a R times R transpose a
transpose B minus a r XM is equal to
this quantity which is minus AR r
transpose a transpose AR XM minus next
star good okay okay I just have to show
this equality and you know both of these
have you have an AR R transpose a
transpose times AR XM that occurs in
both of these right so really you just
have to show that AR r transpose a
transpose B is equal to AR AR transpose
a transpose AR X star is that right do I
get the signs right
oh sorry
aye that's right right okay okay so why
is this true exactly but from the normal
equations right so this this will follow
if R transpose a transpose B is equal to
R transpose a transpose a rx stuff right
because in both cases I'm multiplying by
a R so I'm just showing this is equal to
this these are exactly the normal
equations right if I look at you know
solving the regression problem they are
X minus B then I would get these normal
equations right okay so that's why the
second equation holds questions okay
so let's look at this expression AR -
you know AR R transpose a transpose AR
well what's going on here so this is
these matrices you know this is like a
matrix times its transpose times itself
so it's a matrix - that matrix times its
transpose times itself so the left and
right similar vectors the U and the V
transpose in the SVD are the same is
that clear to people if you haven't okay
so
right so you know what am i what am i
doing there I have a matrix B let's just
call B equals a R and I'm looking at B
minus B B transpose B right and I can
write B it's always sort of useful to
first write it in an SVD so that's the
singular value decomposition of B and I
can write B transpose as the Sigma u
transpose and so if I look at B B
transpose B you know B times B transpose
well the V's are going to cancel because
they're orthonormal so I'll get you
Sigma squared u transpose and then then
the U transpose cancels by the the you
when I multiply again so I really just
get u Sigma cubed D transpose everybody
okay and B is u Sigma V transpose so if
I look at the difference what I get is U
Sigma minus Sigma cubed V transpose
questions okay so that's exactly what I
have here u Sigma minus Sigma cube V
transpose times xn minus X star
questions
okay what do we know about all the
entries of Sigma minus Sigma cube
I'm a bit slow
what's Epsilon yeah exactly
so you know oh all of these entries a 1
plus or minus epsilon zero right because
a R is well-conditioned I'm computing
it's SVD what does it mean to be well
conditioned it means all the similar
values are within 1 plus or minus
epsilon 0 from each other so I have
these these these terms on the diagonal
they're all 1 plus or minus epsilon 0 in
that range and I'm subtracting off the
cube of them and n3 ones
so the difference on each entry is going
to be order epsilon 0 there okay an
epsilon 0 is an arbitrarily small
constant I can set it to be whatever I
want so okay so why don't we look at the
norm of this quantity
okay so the norm of this quantity well
I'm looking at the norm of this now you
as an orthonormal matrix so it doesn't
change the norm I can just drop it Sigma
minus Sigma cube so I get Sigma minus
Sigma cubed V transpose XM minus X star
we set all the entries of Sigma minus
Sigma cubed or order epsilon zero so
this is order epsilon zero I can take
this out order epsilon zero times the
norm of V transpose XM minus X star now
I claim I can just plug back in U Sigma
into that expression because u Sigma is
well conditioned and then when I plug
back in U Sigma I just get a are there
exactly
so its order epsilon zero times the norm
of a r XM minus x star right so it's
actually you know you get an order
epsilon zero from this difference I have
a V transpose here so I have to multiply
back in U Sigma but you Sigma it only
distorts norms by 1 plus epsilon 0 so I
get order epsilon 0 times 1 plus epsilon
0 which is this order epsilon 0 times
the norm of a r XM minus x star
yeah so so the norm so you Sigma is you
know almost like an orthonormal basis
but the singular values instead of all
being one they're between 1 plus or
minus epsilon 0 because it's well
conditioned so it distorts things by at
most that amount yes yeah that was just
that that question so we have a V
transpose here so we took this part out
we have a V transpose and we have an AR
here so to go from here to here I have
to multiply in by you Sigma because you
Sigma V transpose is equal to AR right
that's this SVD now what what happens to
a vector when I multiply it by you Sigma
u Sigma is almost wall condition because
we made you know we made sure that a R
is well conditioned so all the similar
values is you know in Sigma they're all
1 plus or minus epsilon 0 so I can pull
put back in the U Sigma and that just
multiplies this by 1 plus epsilon 0
maybe I should write that is that not
clear
yeah we also just say you pull out I
minus Sigma squared yeah I'm sure
there's a better way of writing this
Sigma times B transpose oh wow I minus
Sigma squared yeah I could leave Sigma V
transpose here and pull out I minus
Sigma squared yeah that's a better way
of doing and then I have to pull back in
the U and U is orthonormal so it
preserves all the norms was that it was
that alternative argument is that clear
any questions yeah Robbie let's say they
are times that vector ARS ago that is
almost one so the length
the right hand side is epsilon times
length yes so what we did is this are
you saying yeah ultimately I want to
relate like what's happening in the M
plus first iteration to what's happening
in the M Federation yeah yeah yeah
question yeah exactly so we're not we're
not done yet
yeah but what have we showed we've
showed some kind of progress right we've
showed that the norm of a r XM plus XM
plus 1 minus X star is it most like a
small constant I can make this like 1/2
times the norm of a R times XM minus X
star the value in the previous iteration
okay so it's dropping and how much does
it drop like if I know if M is equal to
log 1 over epsilon then you know I can
iterate this equality and then you know
the norm in the log 1 over epsilon
iteration is that most the actual
epsilon times the norm in the 0th
iteration the gnomon in the 0th
iteration well we started off with a
constant factor solution so is it most
like you know three times optimal or
something and now we get epsilon times
three times optimal so it's going to be
order epsilon optimal because that's
that's what's happening here but let me
just say what the last line is which is
going back to a question you know what
do we care about we care about the norm
or I say the squared norm of a r XM
minus B all right that's the regression
problem there's a minus B there well
what do we know well the claim is I can
write this squared norm as the norm of a
r XM minus x star squared plus the norm
of a R X star minus B squared why can I
do that
you guys all know this I just want to
make sure people were following yeah so
X star is the optimal solution this is
again the normal equations right so this
is the this is the optimal this is the
part inside of the subspace and this is
you know the optimal distance okay so
this is opt cost and this is what we
just bounded AR XM minus X star squared
that norm and so we just said that this
thing if we set m to be log 1 over
epsilon gives us order epsilon times the
cost of our constant factor solution so
we get order epsilon opt for this term
and this term is opt overall we get 1
plus order epsilon times opt
clear everybody so then why is the
quality importantly than last night
well okay you know in the last line how
are you going to get from this is the
objective you care about and this is the
bound that you have you know inside of
the subspace so so the idea is just you
know to you know to move yourself inside
yes l2 squared yeah yeah that's
Pythagorean theorem
it's like the part from be to the
optimum and the part inside of the
subspace okay so we get a log 1 over
epsilon dependence for regression that's
all I wanted to say about that yeah
solution for the AR regression problem X
Thomas for what I mean I can take a I
mean X star is just I can take the
optimal for AR yeah or X star for the
without without for the a problem right
yeah one day condition number pop up
there because you have to convert that
from this X star to that extra and that
solving the system Rx equals I mean
extra let's say harvey equals extra and
with that problem occurred
if that system is in condition I'm sorry
this X star here this is all with
respect to a r-right 0 fine
oh it's defined in the second line yeah
so X 0 is OSE yeah exactly so this
should be that should be where X star is
defined yeah so X star is then yeah
sorry X star is the minimizer for a rx
minus B and you're getting an X 0 where
the cost is at most a constant factor of
that using X star ax you first replace
that problem with a are X minus B so
like if I'm going to compute a 1 plus
epsilon approximation to ax minus B you
know if I look at a 1 plus epsilon
approximation to this you know what the
cost here it's the same as as the cost
here right I mean this is just a change
of basis so as I'm ranging over all X
I'm getting so I first replace the
original regression problem with the
regression problem where a is replaced
with a R and now everything is done with
respect to a R so X star is with respect
to a R so this is just the no I mean so
this is preserved so approximation is
preserved as well right I mean like if I
get a 1 plus epsilon approximation to 1
I get a 1 plus epsilon approximation to
the other in objective function value if
you care about the actual solution
vector X then you have to map it back
with R inverse X but that's a different
question right all I'm trying to do is
preserve the regression cost solution
yeah
oh okay so this is the you know in
general like it's just the normal
equation right so
all right so let's look at a are X minus
B for an arbitrary vector X right
so I have this subspace AR here right
and here is a rx it's sitting somewhere
here right for some particular X right
now I have my B over here and it's
projection onto this space is given by a
our X star that's the optimal solution
right so by the Pythagorean theorem this
cost the squared cost is this squared
cost plus this squared cost right this
is just the Pythagorean theorem that's
all ok yeah question we have say getting
the matrix all you sell as a
preconditioner is something like LSU all
that kind of stuff
how does that I didn't yeah so so we
have a kdd paper this year you might
want to check it we basically
implemented many you know sketching
based preconditioning methods and but
yeah really the point here of sketching
is just to reduce the condition number
and then feed it into whatever
algorithms that you want yeah yes
second to last and materials but in this
analysis or gradient sense we did for
pedagogical reasons
like when you cover a bond condition
number these things form as a black box
or solder just leave it exclusively here
for this particular circuit that's right
this really is a gradient descent
algorithm yeah and this is really a step
size in the gradient like up to if I put
like a 1/2 squared norm then this would
exactly be like the coefficient will be
1 otherwise you should put a 2 here but
it doesn't change so you want to improve
a lot 1 over epsilon to something else
or yeah wonder whether it's just simple
gradient descent we do say no epsilon is
the same the differences in the
dependence of condition number which
care is close to 1 so if it's clear or
even like average condition number
they're all close to 1 yeah what what
Jason from what am I did using from all
this yeah ok ok so let me just recap the
algorithm we we have our matrix a it's
poorly conditioned so we what we did
first is we found this matrix R which
gives us a good pre-conditioner we did
that in input sparsity plus Pauly D time
independent of epsilon we also have our
matrix a and our vector B and we found a
constant factor solution you know
independent of the actual epsilon in the
same running time now we said let's take
those two quantities and let's run
gradient descent so this is a gradient
descent algorithm at the end of the day
if you output X M where m is like log 1
over epsilon then the claim is that the
overall error that you get a 1 plus
epsilon approximation now why is that
maybe I didn't emphasize it enough like
on the second line here this is relating
the M plus first iteration to the empty
ssin
so you know I can apply it again and
then I get order epsilon naught squared
times AR xn minus 1 and I can keep
applying it if I
plight log 1 over epsilon times if this
is like a half I'll get one half to the
log 1 over epsilon into become epsilon
so that means that this norm is at most
epsilon times the norm of aar X 0 minus
X star in the norm of AR X 0 minus X
star well that's a constant factor
solution to the original problem so
it'll be epsilon times you know 2 times
opt cost does that make sense or no or
no no no sorry where did I lose you like
the you agree I can apply this log 1
over epsilon times and then at the end I
get order epsilon the actual epsilon
times the cost of using X 0 okay and
very quickly yeah yeah it's you know
that's the point that it's decreasing
like a logarithmic number of iterations
makes it you know get all the way down
to epsilon and that wouldn't have been
possible without this condition number
bound like we use the condition number
multiple places in this proof and to get
that we use sketching
so yeah yeah this analysis of places to
any good be conditional right not just
the one that yeah exactly yeah so you
could have applied this to any good
precondition you do need a good initial
solution right case at the end you're
going to get X 0 minus X star it has to
be good potential solution and we're
sketching for that as well
but if you had some other way of getting
a good initial solution you could have
used that sketch is to compute R and
then you using some other sketch to
compute this X naught yeah I mean you
can use the same one and then do a union
bound yeah
oh yeah say what's the computational
cost for each yeah what's the
computational cost what was the whole
point of this so we have loved one over
epsilon iterations right and what are we
doing in each iteration what we're doing
this update rule and we have some vector
X M and all we're doing is matrix vector
products we compute our X M that takes
you know order D time now we have a D
dimensional vector we compute a times
that that takes nnz of a time and now
it's an n-dimensional vector we subtract
it from this vector B that's order n
time now it's an n-dimensional vector we
can prove a transpose send that that's
nnz of a time D dimensional vector order
D time to compute that so it's n plus D
plus NZ of a times log 1 over epsilon
yeah the other questions it's good right
good yeah so you can get log 1 over
epsilon dependence for this problem let
me just quickly move on to low-rank
approximation I wanted to say something
about this ok so here's another very
important problem in linear algebra
machine learning you have an N by D
matrix now think of both MMD is
potentially being large it's no longer
tall thin and think of the N rows of a
as being points in r2 the D you know you
guys know all kinds of applications of
this so a could be a customer product
matrix an a IJ might indicate how many
times a customer purchased an item in
many settings a is typically well
approximated by a low rank matrix it
might just be high rank because of noise
and the goal is to find a low rank
matrix approximating a you know why
would you want that well instead of
storing like enemy parameters for a you
can store like the two factors of a
low-rank approximation like if I write a
is U times V you know where I have rank
K then it's only like n plus D times K
parameters and so it makes it easy to
store and if I'm really removing noise
it could make it more interpretable so
the goal is to find this matrix a and
the natural way of doing this the
standard way of doing this is as Ravi
mentioned is via the singular value
decomposition so I mean I can write a
in a singular value decomposition you
Sigma V and you know the best low-rank
approximation under many different
notions of best is given by the so
called truncated SVD so what is the
truncated SVD well I compute the SVD u
Sigma and V and then I just take the top
K entries in Sigma recall that they're
non decreasing as I move down I take the
top K I leave them alone and I zero out
everything beyond that so Sigma K only
has K nonzero entries effectively
selecting the K leftmost vectors of U
and the K uppermost vectors of V which
are you know called the principal
components top K principal components
and I get some error matrix okay this is
the standard way of doing low-rank
approximation but it takes SVD time okay
and we said SVD is slow it can take like
nd squared time and one must much faster
algorithms you know the SVD is great the
the solution you get a sub K via this
truncated single value decomposition is
the arc minimizer overall rank K
matrices be approximating a in Frobenius
norm but in fact in many other norms any
unitary invariant norm but as we said
it's expensive okay so we want to use
sketching to speed this up okay so yeah
so the goal instead is to relax the
problem and to allow for outputting a
rank K matrix a prime whose cost is at
most 1 plus epsilon times the cost that
you would get by using the SVD
okay and one thing we showed is that you
can do this using sketching in time
which is number of nonzero entries of
your matrix a + and what's typically a
low order term n plus D times the
polynomial in K over epsilon okay
so just some perspective on the bounds
so remember SVD gives exact solution but
it takes nd squared time even if your
matrix is dense like has nd nonzero
entries this still gives you know nd
time versus nd squared time so it's an
improvement and for sparse matrices you
know really gives you an optimal running
time number of nonzero entries and that
is in fact optimal if I have one very
large entry of a and I don't find it I
don't read all the entries then I'm
going to be in trouble because the first
thing any good low-rank approximation
would do would be to try to fit that
very large entry of a ok so so that's
the claim result let me just give you
some intuition how this is shown so the
idea is to again thinking of a as its
rows as being endpoints in R to the D
I've drawn them here the first step in
these algorithms is to compute s times a
where s is one of these wide fat
matrices these sketching matrices that
we've been talking about it has a small
number of rows roughly K over epsilon
rows think of that so when I compute s
times a what I'm doing is I'm taking K
over epsilon random linear combinations
of the rows of eight
right now I can look at the spam the
roast ban of those K epsilon linear
combinations that's a low dimensional
subspace which I've drawn as a line here
of our to the D alright the span of the
rows of s times a it's this low
dimensional subspace have drawn as a
line that's the first step in the
algorithm and the only remaining step is
just to take your endpoints these rows
and project them onto this low
dimensional space s times eight so to
find the closest point in the space s
times eight
and what have we gained by doing this we
still have end points but now instead of
living in our to the D they live in this
very low dimensional subspace this cave
rep salon dimensional subspace if you
remember the SVD the time is like number
of points x dimension squared time we
still have end points but the dimension
instead of being D is now K over Epsilon
yeah question what's what's s times a
versus s a oh that's the same thing
sorry yeah yeah is one of the matrix and
one of them a subspace or something um
yeah sorry so what I meant by this
drawing so I do compute s times a now s
times a has a small number of rows K
epsilon and D columns now I can look at
the span of those K R epsilon rows any
linear combination of those K R epsilon
rows and that's what I'm drawing with
this line it's a subspace of R to the D
right it's all the points inside of that
space and I'm taking each of my n
original points and I'm projecting them
on to that span so this is the row space
of s times a row space of s times a yeah
question so you know the K over epsilon
is less much less than n but actually
for this to make sense
he is wrong right yeah sorry well so
both N and D I'm thinking your visit
yeah
as being large it's it's much less than
both N and D yeah questions okay so you
see like the point of this was to make
SVD efficient we reduce the dimension
from D decay epsilon now you might be
asking a bunch of questions you know
which matrices s work you know all the
usual ones we've discussed work I'll
describe that you might be asking how do
i project the points on to this space
how can I do that very quickly can I do
that quickly in the time bounds that we
want and you might be asking like you
know what am i doing at all why does
this even work why why should i project
them to this space and then solve for
the best rank k space there so these are
the three questions that I hope to
answer so okay first what is the matrix
s all the usual matrices will work so a
matrix of ID normal random variables
with roughly cave reps long rows this
turns out to work or fast Felton
minister also matrix an example is this
subsample randomized Hadamard transform
result with again roughly cave reps on
rows that works or this count sketch
matrix works but now you need a larger
number of rows it's just like I've
written as a polynomial in caver Epsilon
okay the precise dependence is K squared
plus K over epsilon if you're interested
okay and remember these were these
sparse matrices okay so let me just
recap the algorithm and see where we are
the first step is to compute s times a s
is one of these count sketch matrices so
I can compute this you know super-fast
inputs parts of your time the next step
is to project each of the n rows of a
onto the space s times a so it's not
clear how to do that so quickly let me
get back to that and finally once we
have each of the points inside of this
low dimensional space then now we said
SVD is efficient because you have
endpoints in cave reps on dimensions so
we can solve it in n times poly K reps
long time that's that's the algorithm
the bottleneck is step to doing these
projections so how can we project each
of the n rows of a on to s times a quick
wait what is what is projection
projection is just least squares and we
saw all these fast algorithms for least
squares you know earlier in this
tutorial so instead of actually
computing the projection why don't we
approximate the projection so is it fast
up you know there are fast algorithms
for approximate regression I can just
write down what the regression problem
looks like it looks like the following
for the min over rank K matrices x of
the squared norm of X Si minus a why
does it look like this well there's an
argument that the row span of s times a
a contains a good solution I'll get back
to that in a moment but let me just say
why this implements what the algorithm
is doing well you're trying to project
each of the rows of a on to the row span
of s times a so I look at the first row
and the first row of X gives me the
corresponding coefficients you know for
the projection onto the row span of s
times a second row etc I'm minimizing
the sum of squares of differences so it
minimizes the sum of squares for each
row it's giving me the projections and
the fact that X is ranked a while I fold
it in the second the third step into the
second step right because I in the end I
need a rank K matrix here
okay and now there's a fast algorithm
for this so we said we don't know how to
solve this exactly but by using
sketching techniques that we developed
earlier in the tutorial instead of
solving this what happens if I multiply
on the right by another count sketch
matrix R and another count sketch matrix
R here you can show that you know the
cost is preserved okay so it's so it
additional sketching on the right
preserves the cost of this objective
function where the number of columns in
this matrix R doesn't even depend on D
it's now poly caver Epsilon so it's
additional sketching if you put it all
together so I'm skipping the details of
this step then you get overall nnz of a
plus n plus d poly K reps long time yeah
yeah so you know so really this is just
using techniques earlier in the talk
based on least squares regression the
main question here bingling question is
you know why even project the rows on to
the row span of s times a you know why
should that be any good so here's a sort
of a cute argument that reduces low-rank
approximation to regression in a certain
sense so let's look at a hypothetical
regression problem the min over matrices
X of the Frobenius norm of a KX minus 8
okay a K is the best rank K
approximation to a given by the SPD so
what is the minimizer X here
identity right okay so I just set up
some problem let's look at a sketch
version of this problem okay and I don't
have time to define what's called an
what and affine embedding but what you
can think of an affine embedding as is
it's a subspace embedding but for a
shifted subspace by some fixed amount so
I'm gonna look at the column span of a K
but it's going to be shifted by this
matrix a and what you can show is that
there's a generalization of a subspace
embedding called an affine embedding so
that the norm of FA KX minus si is 1
plus or minus epsilon the norm of a KX
minus 8 for all matrices X okay so you
know without the a here this would just
be a subspace embedding property
Rika's AKA has ranked eighth and the
size of a sketch for to preserve a rank
k space is poly k-epsilon okay
are you guys with me here or okay so I
didn't have time to define this ever
anybody but this is a property that you
get it has a small number of rows and it
preserves all these costs okay what is
the solution to this problem
so I've replaced a K with sa k and a
with sa I get this new regression
problem it's a sketch problem well we
know how to write down a closed form
solution for regression right the
solution the minimizer X is si K inverse
times si a pseudo inverse remember we
looked at pseudo inverses we said the
solution to a regression problem is this
pseudo inverse times this so that's the
solution okay what was the point of all
this right we don't know a sub K so why
did I do this so what's one nice
property about this matrix so it's rank
K right and what else can I say about
this matrix
what is it
it's not the identity right because it's
sak pseudo-inverse times si right this
is just si this is a rank K matrix it's
not the identity but what's that yeah
more Penrose the pseudo-inverse will
give you a minimum norm solution but
where does this matrix live like where
do it's row is live what what subspace
do the rows live in getting someone said
it yesterday
si right this is a matrix which has rank
K and it lives inside the row span of Si
and moreover you know by this claim here
that didn't prove we know that you know
any solution I get here gives me a 1
plus or minus epsilon approximation if I
plug it back into the original problem
so if I take this solution X and plug it
back into this original problem then I
get a K times you know this solution
si k inverse si minus a is less than 1
plus epsilon times the optimal solution
cost right all I did is I took this
solution to the sketch regression and
plugged it back into the original
hypothetical regression problem
so what does that mean like look at this
equation it says here's a rank K matrix
it's inside of the row span of Si and
it's giving me a 1 plus epsilon
approximation so it does make sense to
take my rows of a and project them on to
the space s times a because I know
inside it there there's a good one plus
epsilon approximation maybe I'm not
gonna find this one and I'm you know
likely not going to but what am I going
to do after I project my rows onto that
space I'm gonna do the SVD and that
gives me the best rank K approximation
inside of that space so it's at least as
good as this one right is the picture
clear like sorry almost done yeah like
you know we have this this space si we
took our endpoints and we projected them
on to here and now they're all inside of
here and now we're trying to find like a
K dimensional subspace inside of here
which is good and we know there exists
one that's good this one but what we did
is we computed the SVD of these points
inside of here and took the best rank K
solution so that's even better because
everyone has to pay this cost of moving
to s times 8 and by Pythagorean theorem
now I just pay this cost and I'm paying
something even smaller by using the SVD
then you know what I might get by this
particular subspace okay so just to to
conclude you know it's a row it's a rank
a matrix in the row span of s times a
and you know Pythagoras says projecting
the points on to s times a and finding
the best rank K solution inside of s a
gives a rank K matrix at least as good
as this particular one that we found so
that's why that's that's why the
algorithm works that's why it's a good
thing to project onto the row span of s
times a any questions about low-rank
approximation it's clear yeah question
yeah so I didn't I didn't prove this for
time constraints but it's just a natural
generalization of accounts of a subspace
embedding and you can show that count
sketch also satisfies this property yeah
any other questions yeah Michael here a
can be arbitrary dimensions it doesn't
need to be yeah so N and D could both be
large yeah it's arbitrary N and E can
both be large yeah yeah yeah question
yeah yeah good question so I didn't say
what it is for count sketch you can get
something with K squared plus K over
epsilon rows
and that's what actually appears in the
writing time yeah so this is the number
of rows and then when I say Paulie caver
epsilon this disappears in that
polynomial that running time yeah yeah
that's right
you know I would say both okay yes it's
unclear what you said k to be in
practice but there is definitely you
know using some of these trade offs that
I said instead of one nonzero entry per
column if you use a larger number you
can reduce this K squared to something
smaller yeah
any other questions
so the overall running time of this
algorithm is number of nonzero entries
of a plus n plus D poly K epsilon
the approximate projection step inside
of the algorithm is also in this amount
of time yet where is the D let me go
back to the algorithm okay so yeah this
is n times poly K this is N and Z of a
projecting the rows onto this yeah no
actually this this algorithm is just n
times poly K or epsilon so yeah that's
right yeah yeah so when I compute on the
right by a count sketch matrix here the
time can be done in n and Z of a time it
doesn't go into the there's no D here
yeah any other questions okay let me
just wrap up and like a few minutes I
just want to mention you know to
advertise sketching many of the other
applications that it's useful for so
it's useful for these see you are
decompositions
which is what ravi talked about where
you want specific kinds of low rank
approximations where your factors see
contains an actual subset of a small
number of columns of a and r is a small
number of rows of a and you as an
arbitrary rank K matrix these are very
useful low-rank approximation x' because
for example is your columns of a were
sparse then your factorization would
also be sparse your low rank
factorization so you can get fast
algorithms with sketching for that there
are also many robust variance of
low-rank approximation so instead of
minimizing the sum of squares of
differences there's a lot of recent work
trying to minimize the sum of P powers
of differences and a lot of these
problems are NP hard but you can get
approximation algorithms and these could
be much better in the sense if P is 1
this could give you much more robust
solutions than Frobenius norm
there are kernel problems you know where
you have points that are not linearly
separable but you can lift them to a
space where they become linearly
separable and there are sketching based
algorithms
do this very quickly Rasmus Pig has a
nice paper on this clustering you know
k-means clustering you can write this as
a constrained version of low-rank
approximation and you can get you know
very fast algorithms for k-means
clustering based on fast algorithms for
low-rank approximation a lot of these
sketching based algorithms what they do
is they compress the input matrix to
something much smaller and so naturally
they're useful for low communication
distributed protocols where the matrix
is distributed across multiple servers
everyone can compute a sketch of their
matrix and can communicate this sketch
you know to each other which is you know
much less communication intensive
streaming models you often have like
very limited devices like routers on the
network which are processing high-speed
data they want to use you know if you
use a sketch of your input matrix then
you can use you know much smaller amount
of memory then storing the whole matrix
a lot of these albums generalize to
tensors so you can do things like tensor
low-rank approximation you know find you
know outer product of three vectors you
know as Robbie mentioned that would be
the rank one version and the sum of such
outer products sum of K then would be
the rate k version there are algorithms
for that weighted low-rank approximation
you know in in for being Islamic
approximation we're trying to find a
factorization a rank K matrix which
minimizes sum of squares of differences
but you know maybe not all entries are
created equally like maybe some entries
we want to you know weight more than
other entries and so you could have a
weight matrix which multiplies every
entry of the difference you get
algorithms for that structure preserving
low-rank approximation maybe you know
your input matrix a is positive semi
definite then you might want your
factorization to also be positive semi
definite I mean you're trying to
approximate the original matrix so you
might want your factors to look like uu
transpose and there are algorithms for
that regulars versions of these problems
you know maybe on this contour all the
solutions have the same regression cost
but maybe I'm only interested in
solution vectors X
which have unit l 2-norm or at most unit
l 2-norm
or maybe you know at most unit l1 norm
this is the difference between Ridge
regression and lasso and you know
they're algorithms for that based on
sketching and ok so that's it this is
just a summary so thanks
[Music]
[Applause]